Stick stance, Nicholas
OK, sorry
Going off his numbers from last year,
you could make the case he’s become one of the best shooters in the Realm
[Scoff]
You can never have too much shooting, Steph
Klay, your thoughts?
Huh? Um
Yeah. Um.
Yeah, I think it’s unsafe. A bit shaky
I think Swaggy P could be an asset
Lord Commander! Lord Commander!
Yes, Patrick?
A raven…just came in...Woj–er, Shams...Bomb
House Hornets has traded for...Dwight Howard
Hm, good for them. Nothing to concern ourselves with
Thank you, Patrick. Let us know if you hear of anything else
Aye, Lord Commander
Swaggy has his moments, but all too often plays the fool
They said the same of JaVale, but I’d say he’s worked out quite nicely
Aye
I just...I worry how many of these jester types can we absorb until...
Lord Commander! L-Lord Commander!
Yes, Patrick?
Another raven. He’s crossed the Narrow Sea!
Who?
Furkan...Furkan Korkmaz
Oh, ugh, Patrick...
They-they say he might make the Sixers active roster.
They-they say he might make the Sixers' active roster.
Oh, ugh. OK, Patrick. Um. Maybe just notify us if any...big
names change Houses. Understood?
Right, right. Big names. Got it.
I, for one, think Nick’s presence will help
He’s one of the best catch-and-shoot guys out there
Aye, and Lord Walton speaks well of his defense
I mean, I like the lad, it’s just I’m concerned
Lord Commander! Another raven!
Sorry to interrupt, but-but it’s a big name. Hall of Famer!
OK
Vince Carter
He’s joining...House Kings!
We’re not worried about House Kings, Patrick
Come on, Patrick
But...but you said big names and he’s—
He’s bloody 40 years old, Patrick!
I, I don't know.  I, I just...get a bad feeling about him
Here, how about this: Only inform us of anything that actually matters to a house of our stature
So say, one of the Great Houses of the West makes a move that directly affects us
That sort of thing
Right. Something that hurts our chances?
Right
Got it
If you think it’s a good fit. That he’ll know his role
You may be right. This is not the Swaggy P of yore
He’s known as Uncle Swaggy now
Alright, so it is agreed
He’ll be examined by the maesters on the morrow,
and if they deem him fit, then a contract shall be
Ugh, he’s coming. He's coming up. He’s coming back up
Lord, Lord Commander!
Ah here he comes
Lord Commander! I’ve got major news! Multiple ravens!
This better be good
Yes! Ser Chris Paul has been traded to House Rockets
But wait, there’s more!
Jimmy Butler is joining Karl-Anthony and the Maple Knight in Minnesota!
And there’s more, it’s worse
Paul George and Carmelo Anthony will be joining The Brodie on House Thunder
That’s three new Super Houses. All in the West
Again, Patrick? Please
Only bring us news that actually affects our chances
[Chair breaking]
My God! Steph, your chair! Are you OK?
Yeah, just uh, tweaked my ankle. No big deal
Klay? Where's Klay?
Kl-Klay! Get down from there!
Get off the scaffolding! Are you, are you mad?
I'm just trying to see my portrait
Stick stance!
[Scaffolding falling]
Klay?
I’m good I’m good just my thumb
Oh God! Let me help you, Klay
[Debris falling]
-Ah!
-Kevin?
Just tweaked my ribs a bit
Not to worry
[Raven caw]
Ah!
Oh, Draymond! What's wrong with you now?
I don’t know. I was
just sending a raven of my...uh...pelvic area
and the raven, uh...just bit me in, right in the uh...right on the tip of the uh...pelvic area